it's a politically sensitive year for
china local police have blamed it on a
criminal judgment this is much bigger
than that
on sunday july 12 over one thousand
chinese citizens gathered at a bank in
the chinese city of zhengzhou all for
the same reason their life savings had
magically disappeared three months ago
hard-earned money that they deposited
into their bank account poof gone with
zero explanation from their bank and
these were not the bank accounts of rich
chinese citizens by the way this was
money they rely on to pay for food rent
medicine their online access had been
revoked they couldn't use atms they
couldn't make transfers they couldn't
even check their account balance nothing
in total around six billion us dollars
disappeared into thin air with six
chinese banks freezing their customers
accounts without notice
and now these protesters were getting
desperate with no other options the
protesters forced their way onto the
bank stairs demanding their money back
from the bank employees
it was a bank run and that is when it
happened it looked like a scene straight
out of a dystopian nightmare hundreds of
unmarked security forces dressed in
plain white shirts appeared out of
nowhere and they proceeded to show the
protesters no mercy protesters were
beaten kicked to the ground dragged away
it didn't matter if the protesters were
women children the elderly it didn't
matter if they were disabled or pregnant
they were treated all the same one
pregnant woman was even dragged by her
hair and shoved onto a bus and when her
stomach started aching and she begged to
be taken to a hospital the men refused
and all of this was just because these
disobedient subjects wanted their money
back
my name is jake tran and we make
documentaries on money power war and
crime so that you can see the world for
what it really is a giant game of
acquiring power you can't get out of
this game either way so instead of being
a victim why not learn to be a better
player your parents teachers friends
society will never teach you any of this
so we're going to
and these are the bank runs in china
as you all know prices for everything
are out of control lately which means
it's never been more important to save
as much money as you can and one great
way to save money is by cancelling
subscriptions you no longer use the
problem is that i have so many
subscriptions that a lot of the time
i'll just forget to cancel them and i'll
end up wasting money for another month
on something i don't even use anymore
but thankfully there's actually this app
that makes cancelling subscriptions way
easier rocket money formerly known as
true build rocket money is everything i
love about true build with a fresh new
look if you don't know rocket money is
an incredible all-in-one personal
finance platform that has saved me and
3.4 million other members almost a
quarter of a billion dollars in
accounting and one of the coolest
features is helping you cancel unwanted
subscriptions with just one click all
you have to do is securely connect your
accounts rocketmoney will then list out
all your active subscriptions and then
you can cancel the ones you don't use
anymore right within the app my other
favorite feature of theirs is even
better where rocketmoney will actually
negotiate down your bills for you all
you have to do is select the bill you
want lowered take a photo of the bill or
enter the information manually and
rocket money will get busy negotiating
your build down for you they've got an
85 success rate and if they're
successful you get to choose how much of
those savings you want to pass on to
rocket money for their help but that is
just the beginning there are a ton of
other useful features on rocketmoney so
if you want to save money you need to
start using it as soon as possible so to
try it out for free and unlock more
features with premium head to
rocketmoney.com jake with the link below
that's rocketmoney.com with the link
below so they know i sent you thanks to
rocketmoney for sponsoring this video
[Music]
china has around 1 600 village banks
basically village banks are small
financial institutions that are supposed
to be used by farmers village workers
and people who don't need much more than
a place to store their money but over
the years village banks have become more
and more popular because of one thing
their interest rates
you see where the bank of china only
offers 2.75 a year in interest most of
these smaller banks offer nearly double
that at around 4.5 percent a year that
means if someone deposited their life
savings of a hundred thousand dollars
with the bank of china they would earn
around thousand seven hundred and fifty
dollars a year in interest
but if they deposited that same amount
with a village bank they would be
earning four thousand five hundred
dollars instead that doesn't seem like
much but if all it took to nearly double
your interest on your money was to move
your money to another bank it's easy to
see why these village banks became
popular very quickly
there was just one problem
opening a bank account in a bank outside
of your home city or province in china
is illegal
yep in china you're technically not
allowed to deposit your money with a
bank outside of your home base but since
these small village banks were offering
such great interest rates many chinese
people from across the country just
couldn't help but disobey the government
so they started using third-party apps
to deposit their money in these banks
even though they lived thousands of
miles away and for years everything went
perfectly fine
their accounts earned interest they
could easily withdraw their money and
even transferred around the country
exactly like the app developers promised
but then on one fateful day in april
2022 their access to their bank accounts
disappeared
they were completely shut out
some people had put their life savings
into these accounts just to find that
they had no way to use any of it
they couldn't withdraw money they
couldn't transfer it it was as if any
trace of their money had just
disappeared
from there panic ensued people were
sending emails calling the bank's
service lines but no one got any replies
the only explanation anyone offered was
that an eternal network update had
blocked outside access to bank accounts
but as the days turned into weeks people
started getting desperate
this wasn't just a couple of thousand
dollars that got lost it was six billion
dollars
it was insane so people started to get
desperate fast
the people affected borrowed and scraped
together what little cash they could do
to travel all the way to the
headquarters of these banks to demand
their money back
if they could go to these banks in
person and talk to the managers
themselves then maybe just maybe they'd
be able to get some answers
but these disobedient citizens failed to
remember the lessons from tiananmen
square
they failed to remember the lessons from
the coveted lockdowns
they failed to remember that the chinese
government will do anything necessary to
keep law in order
[Music]
in may the headquarters of a village
bank in chencho woke up to a surprise
thousands of angry customers were
waiting to get into the building and
find out where their money had gone the
same thing happened at all the other
five banks that had frozen accounts too
but no matter how much the people
pleaded to be let in to be given real
answers the bank employees refused and
the doors to the banks stayed shut
tensions were rising and if the local
government officials didn't want a
full-blown uprising on their hands they
were going to have to think fast
luckily they had a perfect solution when
the coveted outbreak started in china
citizens were told to sign up for an app
that would track their covet status and
whether or not they had been in contact
with anyone who tested positive it uses
a color code to indicate your kova 19
risk if your profile is green you have
not been exposed to anyone with covid
and are safe to travel and work but if
your code is yellow or red you have been
in contact with someone that had kovit
so say goodbye to your ability to shop
use public transport or go to work as
with any government program from any
government they proclaimed that oh covet
contact tracing is for your safety it's
for the public good of course nothing
more we're not going to use it to
control you in the future but when these
bank runs started happening they thought
well we can't have an uprising on our
hands now can we we need to keep the
peace so they changed everyone's covet
status to red
that way none of them would be able to
travel or gather to protest very
efficient right and their plan worked
perfectly just as all the bank customers
were planning on meeting up at their
banks to protest their health codes
suddenly turned red they were stranded
they couldn't use public transport and
they were forced to stay inside their
homes or hotels even though they knew it
was all just a ploy to keep them from
demanding their money back
one man was held by police in a library
for over 12 hours because his code had
turned red on his way to the bank
coincidentally when he was escorted to
the airport to be sent back home his
code suddenly turned green again
unfortunately it didn't take long for
protesters to figure out what was going
on and when the news started reporting
how government officials had faked
thousands of coveted health alerts the
ccp had no choice but to punish the
local government officials responsible
encouraged by the ccp's apparent support
of the protesters the protesters
gathered at the banks again completely
oblivious that the local government
officials weren't the only ones who were
going to get punished except this time
things turned violent
see in china it's common for police in
china to be at sensitive events
undercover with no uniforms or markings
for example at previous legal
proceedings for chinese human rights
lawyers
foreign journalists and diplomats who
gather outside the courthouse have
occasionally been shoved by unidentified
individuals wearing identical yellow
smiley face badges end quote it's
honestly a genius tactic if you're the
government intimidate and scare your
enemies into silence without them being
able to prove that it was you so the
chinese government decided to use that
same tactic here except this time it was
turned up a notch
that's when a group of uniformed police
officers appeared but they weren't alone
they were joined by a much larger group
of unmarked men mostly wearing white
tops and the strategy was simple the
uniformed police officer stood by as the
white shirts began mercilessly attacking
the crowd people were beaten then
dragged down the stairs of the bank then
dragged onto buses to be taken away from
the protest
the government thought that this show of
force would make their subjects think
twice about protesting but as footage
spread all over chinese social media
more people started traveling to the
banks to protest
something would have to be done to
prevent a full-blown crisis
[Music]
with chaos in the streets the government
finally offered some explanation of what
was going on according to them four of
the six banks that had frozen their
clients accounts were controlled by the
huynan new fortune group the company is
owned by a guy named lou yi the head of
a powerful criminal gang
apparently the huan new fortune group
had gone out of its way to market its
bank's insane investment programs and
interest rates all over the country
as a result more and more people started
opening accounts and investing with
these banks through third-party apps and
with all that money pouring in it was
easy for a guy like lu yi to arrange for
massive loans to be given to him and his
colleagues from that money loans he
never planned on repaying but here's the
kicker according to the investigators
luigi and his team had been running the
scheme for over 10 years more than a
decade and no one had ever realized
according to the government luigi was
now a wanted man and would only be a
matter of time until justice is served
but for the people who need their money
to survive
life isn't looking all that optimistic
it could take months more if not years
for the government to figure out who
exactly was behind the disappearing
money and even then that doesn't
guarantee they'll actually be able to
recover any of the stolen cash
until then thousands of chinese citizens
still don't have access to any of their
money
the problem is this is the ccp we're
talking about here and there are a lot
of other financial problems ready to
explode in china so who knows if this
criminal gang takeover story is actually
true the ccp recently announced a
payback scheme that will return
everyone's money as long as they had
deposited less than 150 000 yen or 22
000
into their accounts
the problem is most of these depositors
had much more than that in their
accounts they put their life savings in
there and now they're left without any
idea if they'll ever see a scent of
their money again
most of the people still protesting are
holding on to the hope that the ccp will
intervene
but even they have to admit that
cheating people out of answers beating
them up and then offering them chump
change in exchange for years of hard
work and sacrifice has shaken their
faith in the party and its leader
and with the twice a decade national
congress that will decide if president
xi jinping stays president happening
later this year this loss of faith means
a lot of heads will have to roll if
president xi jinping plans on keeping
his throne and restoring the ccp's good
name
the ccp has never shied away from going
to extreme lengths to keep their
populist docile and obedient but they're
not the only ones
the american government is just as good
at hiding the things they do in the name
of the greater good
and nothing is a better example of that
than the cia's black site program
for almost 10 years after 9 11 the cia
kidnapped hundreds of arabic suspects
using so-called enhanced interrogation
techniques wink wink and these
interrogation techniques were brutal it
didn't matter that most of those men and
women were innocent they were all
questioned the same honestly the stuff
the cia did to its prisoners was
horrifying and it's some of the darkest
stuff we've ever covered on this channel
but a public video about all the
creative ways the cia found to break its
prisoners is pretty much guaranteed to
get instantly demonetized by youtube
which is why we've decided to release it
as a full-length private documentary
that's only available to channel members
and all you have to do to get access to
this documentary right now is hit that
join button below once you do you'll
have unlimited access to our cia black
sites video as well as other
documentaries on topics like mkultra the
cia's mind control program effrey
jepsteen and the roots of middle eastern
terror
people willingly give universities tens
of thousands of dollars without them
ever teaching you about how the world
really works but when you become a
member you'll get access to all this
insider info for only five dollars a
month
plus there's a refund policy too unlike
most youtube memberships so if you join
and you don't think it's worth it email
us within your first month of joining
and we will personally refund you for
your first month after your first month
there is no refund
modern day bank runs we haven't seen
bank runs in america since like the
1920s so it's super fascinating to see
it happen in the 21st century so let me
know what you thought in the comments
below and if you're new here this is one
of the biggest channels on youtube for
documentaries on money power war and
crime so if you enjoyed this one click
that subscribe button below because we
make multiple videos just like this one
every single week and you have nothing
to lose you can follow me on instagram
at jaketurn for a chance to win a
thousand dollars but that's gonna wrap
it up stay dangerous out there and i
will see you guys in the next one
[Music]
you